properties
default oh
hang on
okay there we go
actually hear me now i
really should have checked that before i
started streaming
but we should be good now okay hey
everybody how are we all doing
i hope everyone's had a good pride month
so far
i had the distinct privilege to get to
perform at a pride event
over the weekend and that was
exceedingly welcome that huh
i i needed that
a lot got your second shot yesterday
that
congratulations ms wicked wolf i'm glad
to hear
that uh
sorry i'm still getting some
accoutrement
put on because i want to look as fancy
as i can i didn't have the time to go
more
elaborate with the makeup because i was
doing non-makeup related things for most
of the day
so i had to throw this together
fairly basic uh
if you were english the phrase would be
you're beautiful you are valid people
are reasonably fond of you
i mean i i suppose that is uh that is
the ceiling
of um of
british um affection i had to think of
the word
kind of quiet uh are people hearing me
okay i might
i can i can make adjustments if i'm
coming in quiet
hang on
and how about now is that better
hope so uh let's see
coming on back i'm reasonably fond of
you
thank you jesse i'm reasonably fond of
you as well
hello carowind gozer um
ooh all sorts of people turning up this
is lovely
steven hey good to see you
my goodness hey there ben
ian lots and lots of folks this is
lovely hold on i'm just just getting my
new bracelet tightened
because there is no such thing
uh as enough rainbows so
clearly i needed to buy this and so i
did
oh that's good to hear logan i'm glad
you're doing well
uh i don't have uh
have a distinct plan uh for this stream
i'm just i'm just drinking in the
uh the glory of being
pride month and so far
not having anything ruin it um
people may recall that last year
june was when uh ms rowling decided to
drop her
lovely lovely essay and so i had that
taking up uh definitely a big chunk of
my output if not my brain
space last pride and the pride before
the hat
the stuff with uh gareth roberts the
writer on doctor who and his anti-trans
stuff
came out so
like we're only halfway through so
hopefully it won't derail but i'm ju
i'm just it's nice to have a calm
pride i mean as calm as it can be with
all the other stuff
already going on um in certain countries
including the one in which i live which
isn't great
but like as cynical as it sounds at
least it didn't start happening
in pride month like i was already
dealing with that stress
so you know you move forward
are you a fan of the new pride flag uh
depends on what you mean by new
um i'm going to assume you mean the one
with the
additional sort of triangle in there and
yes i am i like it i know there's
i um there is i think there is literally
no
version of uh an overarching pride flag
or any individual
pride flag that has not gone or garnered
some degree
of controversy usually within the lgbtq
plus community
because nobody can fight us as hard as
we fight each other
gosh darn it
uh yes we mentioned her name yeah i know
i don't love
i don't love saying it but yeah
yeah jesse it has been a year how
depressing is that
are there still people showing up in
your comments claiming she's not
transphobic
because that that's still uh that still
happens to me
every now and then which is like
is so weird like
i'm not no i almost said i would respect
you more i'm not gonna respect you if
you share her views
i'm just not um but
i uh i will i understand it
better for somebody to say i agree with
her
than for someone to say she's not
transphobic
because uh one is
you know basically taking a stance that
i would rather people didn't take but
you're entitled to do that the other
feels like just flatly denying
reality it's like what parallel universe
do you exist in
where you took that position ah
watching this is secret of nim at the
same time interesting pairing
i dig it i like it uh
oh love secret yeah secretive nym is a
good movie it's
it's an odd film
uh like especially to go back and you
know think about the environment in
which it was
made it's it's a it's a weird film and i
mean that in a good way
it's in a very positive sense it's a
weird film
uh last saturday marked the five year
anniversary of the
pulse nightclub shooting yep yeah
and i i uh
i i had somebody this was a
reply to one of my stories like the it's
the
like pseudo tick tock thing that is on
um youtube somebody replied to one of
those
trying to argue that um pride isn't
necessary because
lgbtq plus people aren't oppressed
and again
it's the denial of reality
like i know how to deal
with someone who
takes a position that people like me
should be oppressed
i'm not going to deal with them politely
but i know how to deal with that
i it kind of leaves you
not being sure what to do
when somebody just flatly denies reality
that oppression of queer people isn't a
thing
i'm sorry what and that seems to largely
just be based
whenever i see that come up it's always
based on the idea of well gay marriage
is allowed like
yes because that's the one and only
thing that uh
we have ever been asking for is the
ability to marry
we didn't care about anything else it
didn't matter to us that you stop
gunning us down and uh
you know mounting legal defense funds
for the people who do
and empowering corporations to continue
to discriminate against us
yeah no marriage that was the one and
only thing
has your daughter watching him she has
it's been a while i don't know
well actually now that she has rats as
pets she
i might be able to get her to watch it
again it's tough to get her to go back
and watch
uh movies that she saw a while back did
you have braces growing up i had braces
in high school
i had i had a lot of work i had a lot of
orthodontia
so like here's the funny thing my teeth
weren't even really that crooked the
problem was my jaw
my um my
upper jaw was too small um so it was
causing like a cross bite and it was
something that was just gonna get worse
later on so i went through a lot of
orthogona orthodontia
uh starting with what's called a hyrax
if you don't know what that is oh god
okay so it's uh it's a hunk of metal
that actually kind of goes across your
upper pallet
right up there and uh so first of all it
it
impedes your speech like you wouldn't
believe um
you have to get used to talking around
the damn thing but
what it is is i it comes with a little
key you
stick it in and crank it a half turn
every night and each crank slowly
very gradually spreads your upper palate
so it was an attempt to make my upper
jaw as large as it should have been for
the size of my lower jaw
now when you do that you get about the
world's
worst splitting headache for about five
seconds
it is very brief but it really hurts
um i went through three of those
because the first one they did when i
was still in middle school
um and ultimately they
they did that too soon because
because um like once they
set my jaw the way they wanted and took
it out
as i continued to grow my jaw just went
back to the way it was before
so i needed a whole new hyrax that's
when i got my second one this one was
the worst one because
normally these things are actually kind
of arched to like actually
um adhere to the curvature of your upper
palate this one was just straight across
which meant that i couldn't get my
tongue any higher than like the top
uh of uh the the the start of my gum
line
so i did actually learn to talk around
that thing but like try
talking without and like force your
tongue to not
go any higher than like the very top of
your teeth
and realize how much that impedes your
speech and realize i was stuck with that
for a little while
that one i was not stuck with for very
long because turnout that didn't even
work put the crank and nothing happened
so they took that one out and i got my
third one which thankfully did arch
thank god
um that one actually took
um i then had to have braces to set my
teeth in such a way that they were
aligned properly now that my jaw had
been reset
that also included pulling two down in
the front
just to make room because i had a little
bit of crowding in the front
um and then once that was done that was
two years of braces and then
finally finally i was left with
retainers
for the upper and the lower and i will
wear those for the rest of my damn
life so that's my orthodont
or the doncha and uh the journey of my
jaw
ugh on the upside because space was made
on
uh my lower i actually got to keep my
wisdom teeth i've got both my top and
bottom wisdom teeth i don't have to have
them pulled
so there's that
i finally finished the irishman movie on
netflix it was an
ordeal that sounds um
that does not sound like a ringing
endorsement
ah
let's see
i i like like popping in and seeing
people having conversations with each
other i see
um ian talking with carowind i see
some folks talking with i see ghosts are
talking with steven like this is cute
i love this uh
and uh like you know you know it's been
fun i've i've um
i've been surprised how well my my
little
shorts on uh pride related topics this
month have been going up there'll be
more of those
um as the month goes on but you didn't
lose the retainers wow that's impressive
no
i i've never lost them that's actually
never happened
i'm currently going through all of the
animated disney films i'm up to the
little mermaid
now like legitimately all of them like
including like the weird
kind of compilation ones like um
the three caballeros and make my music
and stuff like that or just like the
the proper feature length ones
uh are there any specific doctor who's
stories that could have possible
trans or lgbtq plus themes well i mean
there's lots of the i mean the thing
about doing a trans reading or
queer reading of any kind part of the
nature of that is
those themes do not have to be
pre-existing
so i'm struggling oh you had soup good
i'm glad you had something caroline
um so uh while i'm struggling off the
top my head to think of one i have
absolutely no doubt
um that there are stories and themes
um within specific doctor who stories
that
are applicable to a queer experience
um obviously i kind of i kind of did a
queer reading of
the 12th doctor's overall arc as a
character but that was
more about his full time on the show and
less about a
specific um story
so it's something that i'd have to think
about but yeah
probably i'm just not sure of any off
the top of my head
have you watched the sailor moon movie
on netflix
ah no i did not
know that was a thing sailor moon is one
of those things that basically the
extent to which i know sailor moon
is the extent to which i know people who
cosplay as certain characters from it
and that's about the beginning of in the
end of my knowledge of sailor moon
uh
are we railing against hierarchies i
support that
i support that hierarchies by their
nature tend to be
um very very problematic
and uh like look i understand the reason
that hierarchies form in various
environments i understand why
there is hierarchy in the workplace i
understand why there's hierarchy
in government but the broader it gets
supplied the worse it tends to be and
even certain specific situations
it can go really bad a hierarchical
structure is usually really bad for
um uh polyamorous relationships and i'd
say is one of the
big issues that uh most poly
relationships i've seen that fall apart
end up having is somebody insisted the
on a hierarchical structure to the thing
and uh that that is eventually gonna
push somebody away
uh there was the case that
other woman winning her appeal tribunal
earlier this week
not gonna bring myself to name her it's
not the win
that the lgb alliance thinks is i think
i think i'd seen um
inklings of what that was i didn't look
into it i
i don't have the spoons um because i've
i'm in a um a rough enough spot
um sort of sorting out what's going on
in my own country
in regards to all that um so
you'll forgive me if i kind of back
burner what's going on in the uk
it's not because i don't care it's
because my
capacity to know
and be healthy is limited
sad but true uh
let's see
you mean a harem noah harem is usually
hierarchical too because it's
a ton of people underneath one person at
the top so no
that's usually a hierarchical as well so
i'm not sure i'd encourage a harem
uh jesse said you're 10 years old at
heart i
resent that i am 12 at heart thank you
very much
i have the same 70s style drinking glass
i i rather like glasses in this style
there's been hell going on the art
community because one of its members
allegedly
said uncalled for things on a sketchy
social media site
that were racially motivated for years
oh i mean
this is always the thing uh
about um
social media posts and like in general
if you are going to a place where you
think you're anonymous you're not
people can and will figure out who you
are if they have a reason
to and if you're someone uh of standing
in a community somewhere
well that's uh it's gonna give people
reason to
and
the only things that stay secret forever
are the things that exist
only inside your own head
anything you do or anything you say
can eventually come back and bite you in
the ass
whether that's right or not whether
that's fair or not i don't know
but it's the reality no context just
answer the question what is a fish
delicious
i had done a friendship yesterday
because she said homosexuality is a sin
and so was pride told her to go f
herself
that's uh yeah
no i meant hierarchical polyamory is
indistinguishable from my hair and i
didn't mean you endorse harems oh well
see like when i say
hierarchical polyamory my um
my go-to thought is not of a
harem it's it what it usually is
is if in any polyamorous um
setup if any of the people involved are
married
that relationship is almost always put
at the top of a hierarchy
and the um priority is given
to uh the people who someone is married
to
and that and that makes sense
until you think about it because it
means that anyone else who gets involved
their concerns their emotional feelings
their
um agency is going to be made
automatically
secondary now that doesn't happen in
every situation but that's the most
common one that i have seen
is where a married couple or a
relationship
that has just been going on for
significantly longer automatically
receives hierarchical priority
and again while the idea of seniority
makes a certain amount of sense when
you're talking about emotions
you really can't just say
this person's feelings matter more than
your feelings
that's just kind of a [ __ ] thing to do
so you know
question have you seen invincible yet i
have
not um
fun fact the guy who wrote the novel is
robert uh kirkman he's also the show
runner they changed a few things to make
it better
i mean i've heard good things about the
show
i've heard good things about lots of
shows i've heard good things about the
boys i still haven't watched it
so
hey alex i'm glad you could make it glad
nothing was
was clashing
uh
especially if there are children in the
relationship oh yeah that oh
yeah that that really does
complicate a polyamorous setup a lot
um like i
i have a lot of complicated feelings
about polyamory as a practice
on paper i get it i like i really get it
makes so much sense to me but
um in practice having
seen uh
how things actually pan out
yeah it's kind of a disaster
waiting to happen nine times out of ten
and not necessarily because of any
problems unique to polyamory
other than the sheer volume and
preponderance of them
because generally when polyamorous
relationships break down
is for the same core fundamental reasons
that monogamous relationships break down
more often than not because of a failure
of communication somewhere somebody
wasn't being honest about
their feelings or their actions or their
history
or their desires or what they weren't
okay with etc
and not communicating that and then that
gap causing a rift over time
um but the uh
but that is again in my experience uh
at the core of most things that
eventually
fall apart be they polyamorous or
monogamous the only difference is with
polyamory
with more relationships you have more
opportunity
for that to happen at a higher volume or
higher concentration so it's happening
in multiple relationships at the same
time they start layering on top of each
other
so like
polyamory breakups are
messy it's
not fun
i squeal when i saw your review of in
the heights i suspected you were going
to
the stream is so getting demonetized
whatever it's all it's already a pride
stream it's probably gonna happen anyway
oh well uh have you played tell me why
it's about two siblings uh
where one is a trans man i've heard of
it like you need to remember i don't
have um
i don't have a setup that allows me to
do um current era games
have you heard of the tale of
kutrulian i recommend you look into it i
have
not heard of that um oh
hold on ah from
a new type jb lee
um we have a uh super chat reminder the
super chat uh guarantees that i will
read your comment i try and keep up with
the chat
otherwise but the super chat guarantees
it and more importantly
you get a heart because i stole that
from jesse
um happy pride is it just me or has
media not
always done a good job of bi
representation i feel like
works in the past either presented
bisexuality as a joke or titillation for
fanservice
uh yeah by representation
is it's not great
and for a litany of reasons so
there's sort of what you have talked
about
where the idea is
um kind of played for laughs and some
usually
in the context of someone who is
stereotypically fits
the vibe of a gay person saying no
actually i i like
other things so and then if that's
played like a joke
um or especially with bisexual women
just doing it to be like ooh
look i can make out with a girl but what
actually i
at least what i have seen more often is
uh a failure to acknowledge that
bisexual is a thing i think probably the
most
egregious especially for how freaking
long it ran
and they did it the entire run of the
thing um and it's not the only example
but
i feel like it's kind of the ur example
of this is orange is the new black
so piper
the main and interesting character in
the show
uh at the beginning when she goes to
prison
she is in a heterosexual relationship
with a man when she gets into prison she
finds that she is locked up
with a woman whom she has had a
relationship with before
and who she eventually gets into a
relationship with again
and the way that conversation is framed
the word bisexual is
never said instead it is framed as oh
you were gay then you were straight now
you're gay again
the idea that an identity where she
could be attracted to either or
is not even considered in the language
used in that show
it's either straight now or gay now
it's really screwed up and that's and
while
i'm i'm more inclined to be a little
gentler on this uh example that's also a
criticism that does get lobbied at
buffy the vampire slayer and the
depiction of willow who
identifies as gay um
when she starts a relationship with tara
and there are people who accuse
um the show of by erasure because
well she had her relationship with oz
prior to that
now me personally i am less
inclined to be harsh on that one because
post getting with tara willow
only was with women and it's not an
uncommon
um experience for people who are gay to
have been
in a heterosexual relationship maybe
even one where they cared about the
other person deeply
but didn't fully realize their
homosexuality until they were in a
relationship with the same gender and so
the reason i personally
hesitate to call willow
by erasure is because
the as a character
and understanding like she was written
this way they could have written her
differently
but she self-identifies as a lesbian and
the idea that well she was in love with
and had sex with a guy before
dating women means she's bisexual kind
of invalidates her own
agency in what her label is and it also
kind of reinforces the idea of
quote-unquote gold star lesbians
being the only valid kind of lesbian the
idea that you need to have been with
only women and never men
both of which are really toxic notions
but
still broadly speaking there is
there is at least a conversation to be
had and there are those who criticize
that um as by erasure i
i prefer to use the example of orange is
the new black
for that because it's way more clear-cut
because she
goes back and forth repeatedly and they
still won't say the freaking word
uh
i am bisexual i am never straight i
un-straighten straight people
i like that kozer i like that a lot
um i got a super chat from sophie
christina botha you get a heart
thank you so much happy pride happy
pride
f blair white
i i have i've taken
great pleasure in aggressively ignoring
blair white when things kind of blew up
and people started
uh to actually collectively turn on her
not just like the people who have always
acknowledged that she's
kind of awful but like even people who
use tobacco going
oh so like i that what i saw that start
to happen is like good i'd like i don't
need to pay attention to anything after
this
because if she rebounds from this i
don't care i don't want to know
like whatever response she has to all
this i don't care
like just knowing that this happened at
all was uh
was lovely
uh learned the other day that shekinah
nafak voices the trans character and the
new english dub
of the of tokyo godfathers i still
haven't seen that
i should i still haven't seen that
yes i know ms wicked wolf you're very
good at harassing both me
and jesse very skilled at it
uh
aggressively ignoring perfect oh thank
you carowinds so carowind just put uh
in the chat the link to um the
conversation
on bisexual representation that i had
with liz uh my partner
um who's who still largely identifies as
bisexual
um she accepts pansexual as well but she
still
usually goes with bisexual i mean like
the
that's a fine line distinction uh
between those two
uh what what happened to her okay
short version um
blaire white just kept doing what blair
white always does
the the problem was she did it to the
wrong person because honestly what she
did
to and i've gotta forget the name now
um so forgive me for that but what she
did to this person was actually
basically the exact same thing she did
to me
the difference was this was somebody um
that it was
very very easy to find out how wrong
blair was
so what she did blair um did a piece
weighing in on the trans people
particularly trans women
in sports thing and there was uh there's
a trans athlete
who she made the video about and put in
the thumbnail this
this trans um this trans woman athlete's
face and put in quotes i belong in
women's sports deal with it
which not only is something she never
said it's something she did
she didn't even express the sentiment of
and uh in fact had gone had never
competed
in women's sports and was still
competing in men's sports and was not
trying to get into women's sports
so what blair did was actually the exact
same thing she does all the time
take people out of context put words in
their mouth or just flat out say that
they want
that they want or said or claimed the
exact opposite of what those people
actually claim
uh janae murray croc thank you miss
wicked wolf
and it's the same thing she's done for a
while the problem was this time she did
it to someone who was slightly better
known
than than blair normally targets and it
was someone who
all the claims blair made it was a
single google search to figure out
that she was 100 wrong in
every single assertion she made now like
i said it's basically the same thing she
did to me
the difference was to realize that what
she said about me wasn't true
you would have had to have watched not
only the entirety of the video that she
cherry-picked bits of me
from to do her takedown but you would
also have had to have watched other
videos i might it would have taken
research to realize how wrong she was
and what she said about me
it took no research for people to
realize how much she lied about jenae
murray croc so that was what nailed her
um because how wrong she was is how
wrong she's been about almost
every time she's done this sort of thing
not
i'm not gonna say every single time but
definitely uh what happened to me
is what happened to numerous other
people so it was just
fun to um to see her get taken down
for the exact stuff that she's been
doing for ages
but for stupid reasons was getting away
with
oh we have a super chat so we have a
heart
to give to chris mcgovern
uh thank you happy pride month nathaniel
thank you chris
i appreciate that greatly
uh as a bisexual person i can say it's
weird how my family says i'm straight
or gay depending on the relationship i'm
in when i've tried to correct them they
think i'm polyamorous
oh my god
not that there would be a problem with
you being polyamorous but for
jesus oh
who's your favorite classic doctor who
companion and who do you think was the
best
um i go back and forth
between jamie and ace and i have a hard
time picking one i think
uh if you were to really press me on it
i'd probably go with ace but they're
both really
good um
the tale of cu cullen
is uh an ancient irish folk tale
might be contributing factor to the
creation of the hulk huh
i am unfamiliar and that is interesting
uh
uh my first pride properly accepting
oh sorry uh oh
we get you get a heart
i i don't know how else to pronounce it
well oh god there's capitals
going with that my first pride properly
accepting
or acknowledging my gender fluid pan and
a
self have to you happy pride you
wonderful person that oh
that is wonderful to hear that is
absolutely wonderful
the
the weight that gets lifted
that you didn't even necessarily realize
you were
carrying when you're able
to understand who you are
and then just be that
you don't even realize
how much it weighed you
down until it's not there anymore
it's like how
some people will exercise like with uh
with weights strapped to their ankles or
their wrists
so that they get used to doing the extra
work to
carry the extra weight so that then when
they take it off
they're all the stronger for it not to
say that the weight
that queer people carry makes them
stronger it
doesn't it does nothing but weigh us
down
but it's similar in the um
in the principle of you just go through
life and it's just
there and you don't
really know until it's gone
and it being gone
is almost impossible to describe
and my heart goes out to anyone who has
not
yet been able to shed that weight
and my love and support goes out to
everyone who
has or is trying to
it's just
it's funny because for me
i never felt
that strongly
closeted i didn't feel like i was hiding
that much
i don't think that the weight that i
carried um
was that much
certainly compared to other people who
like legitimately had to
press everything down so hard and be in
utter denial to themselves or to other
people
i didn't have that so i don't think the
weight that i carried was that much
but i carried it for
so long it didn't matter that it wasn't
that much
it just having it gone
it was like i was i was in lower gravity
it was like on the moon and suddenly i
could jump 10 feet
so i had another um
super chat from new type jb lee
you get another heart let's see buffy
question
thoughts on dawn did you think the
characters overhated
i feel there's a lot of interesting
ideas with don also xander is the worst
i i still don't have it
in me to hate xander as much as some
parts of the fandom hate zander
that said i do understand why they do
hate xander part of my own reluctance to
do that has to do with the fact that
at the time when i watched the show for
the very first time
xander was the character i related to
the most
xander was not that dissimilar to my
masculine life at an earlier point in my
existence so i related to
and liked xander a lot and even though
that's not my experience anymore and i
have a harder time relating to that now
i still remember how much i
did and it just
but i get all the criticisms of xander
now as to dawn
dawn is
don is one of those characters not a
million
miles away from
um clara on doctor who
um or connor on angel for that matter
which is her presence
does interesting things to the story and
to the other characters
but people who tend to have issue have
issues with
the characterization or in the case of
someone like clara the lack thereof for
a while
so it becomes a clash and like i'm a
little bit of a connor defender
because i really like what his
presence does to the story most of the
time
not all of it but a lot of it i really
like
how his presence and his involvement
impacts the other characters
and there's a similar argument to be
made about
dawn except i personally am not of the
opinion
that or at least i don't feel that what
dawn
brought out of the situation was as
interesting
um and she also suffers from the
standard
um kid-sister problem
which is that she is a character who is
intended to
irritate um the central characters
primarily buffy
she is designed to be annoying to buffy
but we've already known buffy for four
seasons by the time she shows up
so we like buffy so if buffy doesn't
like somebody or is annoyed by someone
we're going to be inclined to think that
same way about her
is she overhated maybe a little i don't
think she's the worst
but i think there's plenty of reasons to
be annoyed with her and yes jacob i am
absolutely avoiding owl house season 2
spoilers
there will be none of that here thank
you very much
actually i think i might even keep on
top of this for once
i'm going to pop on over to the discord
see what questions are there a reminder
if you support me on patreon one of the
perks
um for two dollars and up per month is
the uh
discord and that is the one other way to
guarantee that i will
uh read your comment or question other
than super chats is to put it in the
appropriate channel on the
council of geeks discord server actually
before i go
over there um i realized i feel way more
generally human than specifically male
so he they has stuck
now figured out and by years ago as well
well congratulations daniel
um okay so i'm gonna pop over to the
discord
that's i'm in the wrong place
i'm on too many servers i should get off
some of these
um okay it's loading
painfully slowly why is it that slow
i do not know am i a poet
and didn't know it dear god i cannot
believe i just did
all right what is going on
okay screw it i'm gonna i'm gonna try
and pull up
uh it on my phone instead because on my
computer it is being
a dumb not just um
adam i don't know why i felt the need to
do that
but here we go uh middle of the night
for me but i hope you have fun happy
pride month aw
thank you moa um i have to wake up five
hours after the stream starts have fun
lots of people who couldn't make it uh
sorry to miss out this week been plagued
by headaches oh
yeah no definitely tend to that um i'm
not lgbtqia myself but your lgbtqia
content is my favorite part of your
channel besides doctor who
uh um you have helped me to learn and
understand more and better support
friends and younger members of my family
who have come out thank you
oh oh that's so sweet i
i love getting comments like that
because um
it's the kind of thing that i
hope to accomplish but
i can't bring myself to expect that i do
the idea that i might have actually
helped
people lacking um
[Music]
direct experience either because they
are lgbtqia plus or they
have someone close to them who who is
and that
i could in any way help them better
understand
that is uh
that is definitely something that i
hope to do and
don't set as an expectation for myself
because
in my heart of hearts i tend to think
that's unreasonable you can't
expect to have that impact but
to quote the doctor
it's the best i can do so i'm gonna do
it
and i'm gonna keep doing it until it
kills me
last part of that was a little dark
right keep in mind that's a quote from
uh the
the uh finale to
series 10 when he was expecting to die
so
i'm not expecting this to kill me but uh
similar sentiment why do you hate greece
it's
where do you want to start do you want
to start with the uh
with the misogyny do you want to start
with the um
rapey vibes do you want to start
with the uh implication that a
woman should change who she is from the
ground up for a guy
do you want to start with the fact that
the characters are just kind of hollow
and i don't really care for love stories
anyways like
there's a lot of reasons i just
[Music]
i'm a demisexual lesbian and you have
helped me accept oh
my gosh cora thank you that's that's
amazing
[Music]
and the songs in greece like some of the
songs
are okay or at least i understand
why they appeal yes
you could give if you could give any
doctor and show runner a series together
who'd you pair up i personally don't see
capaldi's davies series
honestly i just want to give capaldi and
moffat one more season
and have missy be the companion
that's that's what i feel deprived of
i watched uh ammonite today the kate
winslet
sorca ronan film that inspired snl's
recent lesbian period drama sketch
i had not heard of that at all but um
yeah that that all tracks vera hates
greeks because they have taste
i thank you caleb thank you very much uh
did you hear they canceled the captain
jack comic i hadn't heard but that would
have been part of the wave of
all the other related material that they
cancelled so
i'm not exactly surprised you definitely
you definitely have helped me learn and
understand more about the lgbtq plus
community my youngest has told me he's
gay
um oh
no sorry message was rejected i was in
the middle of reading it
so uh i'll i'll leave it at that i'm
assuming you had a reason to retract it
and that's
that's your reason um the doctor falls
the most quotable piece of fiction ever
uh i also have seen a trans reading of
bill as a cyberman will need to read
more
uh more on that ooh
huh i'm curious to know how that
read plays because
the only way that i could think that
that works
is the idea that cyberman bill
is um that the cyberman
is the equivalent to
her gender assigned at birth
um and that
bill as bill is her chosen identity
that's the only way that reading could
work for me because if the idea is that
the cyberman is the
gender transitioned into that would be
all kinds of f'd up
if it weren't for the conspiracy
theorists would q plus be a good
shorthand for lgbt etc
the initials are mouthful i mean like
look
i'm partial to just
using the term queer um that's part of
the reason
i use it in
in thumbnails and video descriptions
it's a good punchy um blanket term
you do have to be careful especially if
you yourself
are not um
part of the community
because um the
god i got okay i'm gonna divert for a
second
i got into a fight on twitter last week
about overwhelming whether or not queer
is a slur
so education time
i'm probably going to do a short on this
too but
so broadly speaking i'll put some
caveats on this in a minute
broadly speaking queer at present is not
a slur
especially for people who are part of
the queer community to use it
now has it in the past
been used as a slur torch towards lgbtq
ia plus people yes it absolutely has
but it has been actively worked to be
reclaimed
by this community since the 80s so this
isn't even a new move to reclaim the
word
queer and this this was part of oh
boy this is part of why i got into a
fight
on twitter because this person who i'm
not going to name
or or anything else or give any
identifiers actually
this person was
coming at joel my thumbnail artist
for putting the word queer in some of
the thumbnails because he was showing
off his work trying to
see if anyone else wanted to hire
additional work if you need thumbnail
work or graphic design at all actually
by the way um you you can hit up joel
um if you don't have his contact
information ask me i'll give it to you
he's great but anyways he had put up
examples of his work and some of those
included the word queer in the thumbnail
because
as a queer person i asked him to put it
there
and this person on twitter came at him
saying it was a slur
and even when people pointed out it was
requested by
the queer person employing him
this wasn't something he decided to do
on his own
this person tried to this person tried
to equivocate
the word queer with the n-word and
holy crap no um
and he here's why um
yes the word queer can and has been
used as a slur to denigrate
and put down and oppress us
but it's also a word with a pre-existing
meaning
a neutral descriptor that was
not a slur and did not refer to a
certain type
of person in any specificity for
centuries it just meant unusual
not even necessarily in a bad way
so queer is a word that had meaning
before being used as a slur
and has been reclaimed so that it is no
longer a slur
the n-word has no
existence outside of its
use as a means of oppression that's why
the word was created
and whatever reclamation of the word has
happened happens
solely within the black community
and they are the only ones who have any
business ever trying to reclaim it
but that word existed from the beginning
solely
for the express purpose of oppressing
and keeping down a group of people
so it's not even close to equivalent
all that having been said
things can still be slightly dicey
if you yourself are cisgender and
heterosexual
using the term queer not necessarily
because
it is um automatically a problem the way
that say
a white person saying the n word would
automatically be a problem
but in that if you aren't part of that
community
it's going to at the very least
immediately hang a question mark over
your use of that word as to whether you
are intending it as a slur or not
so that's the main reason for people
outside of the queer community using it
is a bit iffy
not because it's automatically bad for
you to do so but because
you're gonna have to be prepared to get
some sideways looks from people who
don't know you well enough to know
how you're using it if that makes sense
uh so i got i got one more
uh super chat thank you so very much
that is a heart
for carl carlile the cinephile
i came out as bi this year i just want
to thank you for helping me come to
terms
with who i am keep up the good work oh
that's wonderful carlisle i'm i'm so
happy for you
and thank you thank you so much
uh asking why somebody hates grease is
like asking why you hate black licorice
excuse me i like black licorice
so i'm gonna have to ask you to step
outside that's fine
i do i do actually um legitimately like
black league
which which carowind actually already
pointed out so
she beat me to it
uh let's see i'm gonna i'm probably
gonna wrap it up soon we've gone almost
an hour
um and i i kind of want to take a
relaxed evening if i can at all
i watch bo burnham inside after watching
a review i watch it twice already i'm
going to watch it again
that thing that that thing's a piece of
work and i mean that in the best way
that's probably going to go on my top 10
list at the end of the year
um actually i can almost guarantee it
watching casino royale again tonight um
and wanted to ask when the next bond
movie review you will drop
um i i have a review for
um uh for your eyes only
that i have shot i need to edit it um
but that's gonna go up this month
am i an old conservative
do i look like an old conservative
oh new type jb lee again
thank you so much about dawn i guess i'm
a defender cause
there is the met because uh it's
thematically interesting
about a girl who discovers her existence
is a lie even her memories and she cuts
herself to see if she is human or not
like
i feel i feel like
a version of buffy where dawn is the pov
character would be a much
better way to do justice to that aspect
because since she isn't
um then she's always going to be seen
by the viewers as an intruder because
one minute she's there and then she's
not
so well i don't think you're wrong
i do think as presented it's difficult
to
empathize and go on that emotional
journey with dawn
because from our perspective as an
audience she is always an intruder
um so
um i do think that the best way to get
good mileage out of that
would be to do something more
specifically from her
point of view uh this is the only time
multiple people have told me that they
like black licorice and
my mind is more blown than anything else
sorry we were just joking around i won't
hold it against you
uh i am i am gonna i am gonna wrap it up
though
but yes i'm gonna i'm gonna try and um
get back on track with the james bond
reviews i was commissioned for
um trying to remember i think
i think i think it's licensed to kill
is the dalton one i was commissioned for
and um
uh the world is not enough
for brosnan and i'm struggling now to
remember which
craig won i think skyfall
i'm not sure off the top of my head
though
it's i i i've got i've got a list it's
all written down
um oh the mina
and channel thank you so much you get a
heart
always enjoying and appreciating your
videos have a great evening thank you
you as well i am going to um
finish my water and
call it a night thank you everybody for
tuning in
i hope you have a great rest of pride
and um just
do your best to be well
be safe be kind
and remember that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are
loved you
my friends are the council
and i only run the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned my cavity